also here tonight senator tom cotton of
arkansas senator you heard us discuss
this joe biden and his buddies moved
everything off to china and now it's a
mess because our destiny's tied up with
the chinese anything happens in china
affects us uh like a pandemic or a uh
supply shortage
and joe's saying oh whoa i'm just
learning about this what do you think's
going on here
uh jesse you put your finger on the root
of the problem that for 30 years we've
sent so many of our jobs and
manufacturing to china it's not easy
these days to buy a piece of furniture
or clothing or shoes or toys for your
kids or christmas decorations that
doesn't come from china but now that's
been the case for 30 years joe biden
helped create that he also helped though
helped create the short-term problem
because of the inflation that our
country sees through the supply
shortages from paying people not to work
from locking down our economy all of
this was foreseeable he celebrates today
that they're going to keep the port of
los angeles open 24 hours a day which
they probably should have been doing
months ago at the same time the white
house is saying that
you're probably not going to be able to
get everything you want for christmas
well i mean who's going to save
christmas for americans pete buda judge
i mean please pete moody chad couldn't
organize a one-car funeral he's not
going to organize our nation's ports and
railroads and highways and airports no
fauci said we might not even be able to
celebrate christmas and now the white
house is saying there's going to be no
toys under the tree it's going to be a
dark winter if you think hey you could
get another variant coming through the
northern united states you have home
heating bills they're going to be
skyrocketing going to be a lot of
unhappy americans in the next couple
months senator cotton i got to ask he
said he made some phone calls today joe
biden got on the phone called some said
he's going to call companies tell him to
hire more truckers does he hear how
silly that sounds
he can't get truckers because no one's
working because of all these mandates
and free money
well for months jesse the united states
government under joe biden has been
paying people not to go to work that's
one reason why it's been so hard to get
workers and now joe biden is threatening
people threatening to fire people if
they won't get a vaccine even if they've
had the coronavirus even if they have
natural immunity and again he's acting
surprised that this shortage is
happening and he's acting like a photo
op at the white house is going to solve
it that is going to put money back in
people's pockets when they're paying
three or four dollars a gallon for gas
and they're paying an extra 20 25 a week
for their groceries i mean i guess on
the bright side they don't have enough
money to spend on christmas toys under
joe biden's inflation so maybe it won't
be a problem they don't have enough toys
at the shelves on the stores to buy them
in the first place well we talked about
it at the top this guy's never run a
business hunter biden is his portfolio
manager if hunter is in charge for
balancing your checkbook i i think i
think this country has a lot of problems
you just learned the president shared a
bank account we only know of one with
his son we don't know where money was
coming from if foreign wires were coming
through to hunter and joe had access to
that account this is the guy who's now
in charge of a you know multi-trillion
dollar economy and it looks like this
recovery is stalled out
yeah the the economic recovery under joe
biden is about as healthy and productive
as hunter biden's financial life i mean
maybe hunter biden can cr maybe he can
make some new paintings for all
americans for their christmas gifts when
they can't get the toys in
yeah no supply chain problems there
right everything's just flying off the
shelves at the gallery
it's unbelievable it's a supply chain
supply chain of crooked money straight
into hunter biden's pockets and now we
know that that floats a lot of the
entire biden family and we knew that and
the media covered it up and now it's
come out because we knew it and uh they
still don't want to touch it senator
cotton thank you so much let's
straighten these guys out in dc please
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else